you guys know there's a statue of Lenin
in Seattle whoa whoa I did not know
still standing makes sense they'll pull
down Hans Christian Hague who fought to
end slavery they'll tear down the
founding fathers but uh not him the
problem with Lenin is he looked so cool
dude
just a shadow goatee just angular it's
kind of like the problem with socialism
in general yeah it's really great like
Lennon is so what a unique looking dude
they've modeled video game character I
mean I think that the reason I think he
looks cool is because I've seen video
characters 16 foot tall statue of a
Lennon in Seattle 18 foot yeah they even
had to exaggerate that
I lived in Fremont briefly I don't even
know if we should know
he killed no we shouldn't we definitely
shouldn't Lennon is like Marxism
leninism is the idea that has like led
to all sorts of killing so Lenin's
perspective was socialism London was
like Marx is wrong socialism will not
just happen right if the idea was you
had feudalism then you had capitalism
and then once capitalism made enough
product and stuff then you would have
socialism and it would just happen right
and then after social once you had
socialism then the people would start
realizing that socialism works and then
that the government itself is redundant
because people are doing the things that
need to be done not the government and
then no was that sorry yep apparently
it's for sale
and the statue I'll get it and uh in
1996 they wanted 150 000 for it right
which of the equivalent today would be
280 000 for it what say uh we buy it and
then destroy it I so badly want to do
this I love this I want to leave it I
mean it's a historical artifact just
stick it somewhere that is a fair point
I'm not buying I'll pee on it
I'm into that I think you need to do
more than just people you know what I
would love to paint it make it look like
him in real life or something put like a
clown face on it that'd be crazy oh my
God you should be different wigs and
stuff on them buy it and half bury it at
Freedom oh it's just head sticking out
but charge people money to defile it you
can walk by and smack it with a with a
shoe chicken eggs at it we could put it
in a shooting range and you could pay
money dude you should hold on to it like
any good statue do you think they'd sell
it to me if I told them like my
intention is to bring it to a shooting
range we should stop talking about this
right now
after show only we just want to repaint
it like the Statue of Liberty I got a
question for you guys about the
president do you think because I was
thinking last night
oh man a lot of the people that watch
this show enjoy Donald Trump so I don't
want to be too much of a dig on him but
last time I was like I feel like voting
for Trump right now is like the Lazy
Man's vote it's just like go in there
and just do it uh I don't even know but
like Vivek is the intellectual it's the
challenging route because he actually
has a plan you have to think about it
and actually learn things to understand
how to manipulate our government perfect
was talking about the uh stuff with uh
Infowars and stuff like that so another
another
good thing about the Vegas he's talking
about these you know these kind of
things that other politicians don't seem
to to be talking sorry super complicated
stuff too like it takes hours to listen
to it and then you might have a piece of
it but like that's the challenge I want
to throw out there that Vivek also said
that he would pardon Ross day one
Ross Albrecht Russell bricked Silk Road
um you know and I think that that is for
me that's that's a number one reason to
vote for him I I do like what he's doing
I do like that he's going to these shows
and and being real which politician in
America is real you know and I think
Vivek is he's he's coming to all these
shows and and you know doing the work
um it's really easy to get a quick sound
bite and just you know something that
your manager gave you and like blah blah
blah I think everybody should have this
and then he's actually there explaining
things he's also talking about cutting
you know lots of government agencies and
I love that part yeah huh should we
should we launch a give send to go
for the purpose of purchasing the Lenin
statue recover for recovering the statue
we must recover it from the capitalist
oppressors that have colonized his
likeness they're selling it for money is
really hilarious by the way it's like we
made it and we're going to sell it to
you for a lot of money I mean six
figures this is no joke you could buy a
house for that money I mean that's a lot
of money for a big pile of but I'm I got
to tell you rock I hear me out I'm
fairly confident that if I bought this
and then brought it to a big piece of
rural land and said for five dollars you
can defile it in any way you want take
my money oh I'd make so much money take
my money all of it just let me let me
please
for me and this one's for my dad yeah it
would be Floridian pilgrimages of people
being like why don't we just put it in
Florida let's put in the capital Latin
America Miami and let's just you know
let the people that have had to flee
their countries in recent times take
care of it for you I I like it take care
of it if it was about if it was the bald
statue of Lennon I'd be into it but he's
got a hat on a lot of respect for Paul
guys we don't get rid of that hat
there's um what is the non-profit the
victims of uh communism victims of
Communism it would be cool to like buy
it and donate it to them and say like do
with it what you will make it special
look I think you should definitely do it
gives and go and see if people will
donate to do it and get people to you
know if I were to do a gift set and go
it would be like there it would have to
be to give it to the victims of
Communism Memorial or whatever so I
would I like in fact I would reach out
to a how about to use it to stop current
communism or at least educate people on
the current communism because communism
isn't over but when you've got an island
90 miles from our Shores that is
full-on communist it's adapting to to
the monetary what I'm saying is Chinese
communism isn't real
hyper communism is real communism what
I'm saying is I would not crowdfund to
buy this to personally own if we do a
crowdfund it's so that an anti-communist
organization
can can get ownership of it like I'm
saying like I don't like the idea we do
a gifts and go everyone gives money
which effectively gives me I don't want
the statue like if I was going to buy
the statue on my own I'd buy it on my
own and I charge admission for people to
file because that's hilarious turning
him into a capitalist spectacle for
capitalists to make money off of is just
oh it's icing on the cake I love it so
it's a possibility
um the first question is will they will
they actually sell it to someone they
know is going to defile it
uh but I think they legitimately would
sell it to the victims of Communism or
some non-profit but it's also a question
too would would like a non-profit like
the victims of Communism want to be
involved in something so crude would
that be besmirching the memory of those
who are who are killed by these monsters
no this was created in the in
Czechoslovakia during the the Soviet
Union's reign in 88 1988 and then after
uh the dissolution of the USSR
was brought to America in 1993 so I
don't think this is has anything with
people that loved communism this is
people that fled the Soviet Union
uh it was made by a bulgarian-born
Slovak sculptor named Emil venkov I
don't know what his communist ties were
I'm just you know it would be hilarious
to see what antifa would do if we're
like guitars now to be very confused
uh it's made of bronze maybe we could
polish it I think I have to buy it dude
what am I alive for if not to buy the
statue of Lenin I love that so that you
do so that we can topple it have Phil
Labonte stand on top of it
he's got like a thing behind him you can
sit on maybe you can set up a drum kit
or something I really I'm gonna pursue
this because you just think like I'm I
look at the great works I I look at the
the
you know I play Civilization right and
in Civilization every so often you get
great figures so it's like you'll get a
little dude it'll be called like
musician and then you can place him
somewhere and he makes culture but every
so often you'll get like it it you'll
like Beethoven appears and he's a guy
you can go and then create a great work
and the great work creates cultural
influence and I think about where are we
today where's all of the significant
significant cultural stuff that matters
to people of this generation
I saw a meme and it's a it's a bunch of
cassette tapes and it said all of these
uh albums came out within like four
months of each other yeah everything
awesome right use your illusion one and
two Pearl Jam Nirvana uh never mind it's
like some type of Pilots bad mode bad
motor finger sound garden all yeah
sounds like a good year dude it's crazy
and so I'm thinking today
what what have we done this year what
has anyone done where it's like we're
gonna remember that crazy thing Oliver
Anthony I'll say for sure I'm not saying
nothing's been done I'm just saying like
think about the things that we we should
create to create that memory and that
cultural uh Waypoint as it were so I
kind of feel like you know Phil Labonte
standing on the the ruin of a shattered
Lenin statue singing in mockery of
Communism sure is one of those things to
be done light it from underneath that's
gonna look why oh yeah put some lights
underneath the thing it's like free with
like a ladder on the back or steps on
the back so you can climb up onto it
really easy Tim cast anti-coming you
know like I I don't like the destruction
of statues Confederate otherwise and
part like
the burning of the Library of Alexandria
is is a horror story to me like you know
if if someone's like you want to hear a
horror story you tell me about ghosts
and demons I'm like oh that's cool but
tell me about the burning of the Library
of Alexandria and I'm like and I'm like
I'm hiding like no the knowledge so you
know destroying the statue for no reason
just like toppling it is stupid
but doing something cultural artistic
with it is important you know one things
I Like About That civilization reference
you're talking about great people when
you're your Society produces a great
person Beethoven Steve Jobs whoever when
you get multiple great people all
produced at the same time in history
they can come together to create a
golden age and that's what's happened
with the internet
we're in a golden age we're in a time of
immense crisis but we're in a golden age
while we're Suffering The Crisis so it's
that much easier
we've got to use it while we have it
because it's every age comes to an end
maybe we write a song
and then we can use it in the music
video
like I'm thinking like can you create an
artistic work that represents
you know we we we deride and explain how
bad communism is and there's there's a
message that I think people often say
that doesn't get enough attention it
doesn't permeate enough and it's that
the Communists were infinitely worse or
I shouldn't say infinitely were
substantially worse in many ways than
the Nazis the Nazis committed probably
one of the most like evil atrocities but
the Communists had this long drawn out
70 years or longer 100 years even still
to this day with what China has done to
the uyghur Muslims it's just this
endless history of hundreds of millions
of dead the holiday more happened before
the Holocaust right and these things are
horrifying and Evil
so so at least saying like guys we get
it we we hate Nazis but can we also add
communism into I don't understand how we
don't have comedy I mean how I don't
know depending on whatever number you
want to use for how many how many people
perished under Nazism but communism that
number is so much more uh maybe 200
million people I mean it's just so big
oh oh my God Dylan butter says buy the
statue put a chicken bridge over it yeah
and play Lennon getting crapped on live
that's a really good I love it just him
like half out of the ground
City would be the best thing ever poor
chickens just having to deal with this
thing no the chickens would that we
would put the perch on it yeah where
they sleep and they just crap in their
sleep and it plops right onto Lenin
love it oh perfect I'll take I'll take a
look at it to be completely honest I
mean it's not like I just have 300 Grand
to buy a statue
and shipping that's going to be Hefty
how much is this that's going to be a
serious cost to ship you get a get a
bunch of people to do a road trip go
pick it up that's why that's why I'm
like I really do think we could muster
up a crowd fund between it's not just
about like what this show can do but if
I reached out to a bunch of other
personnel and said guys let's promote
this and get a non-profit to buy the
statue and then do something critical of
Communism with it we'd raise that money
overnight I agree and I love that idea I
think that there is communism still
today and a lot of people just don't
know don't know what it is don't know
how miserable it is don't understand the
crisis
um again going back to Miami over a
million people who have fled communist
regimes live in Miami today and so
um yeah if you you gotta live it or talk
to people who've lived it or do
something like this buy a statue and
make sure people know what's going on is
the reason it fails and just always has
failed is because
sounds great everyone's going to get
enough and then he gets to the point
where you have so many people we don't
have enough resources now everyone can't
have enough it fails because human
beings are not geared to be socialists
well in small groups we are like in a
family unit
that's your desire to give to your
children to give to your wife to give to
the people that you love now what desire
do you have if I tell you hey
I really need some money and I just I
want it because I want it what drives
you to go make that money for me
if you were my neighbor and you were
like I want some money because I'm gonna
plant some corn I could see like but Ian
you're talking about the when when so
you're talking about a concept that is a
has to be a at least National right so
you're talking about millions of people
and things work differently at different
resolutions right so so the way that the
way that uh um like
family works there's only four or five
you know that six whatever ten in your
immediate family communism is fine for
that you know because the people that
you're supporting need you to take care
of them children can't go out and
support themselves and taking themselves
that works but once you get to like your
neighborhood you can't have a communist
neighborhood you can might have some
kind of you can have social programs or
social get-togethers and and your
neighbors can help each other but it
can't be just like Hey Joe makes a
hundred grand and Bill makes 30. so
we're gonna take you know Joe's money
and give some of it's a bill and stuff
and that's the way that it ends up
working out that ends up creating
animosity it ends up making mistrust it
ends up making people not feel like
working there's this idea called The
Tragedy of the commons right so if no
one owns something no one takes care of
it because they don't feel like they're
responsible for it that's one of the
things that property does right if you
own something then you feel like it is a
part of you on some level and it gives
you the desire to take care of it to
make it better here to to build on it if
you don't have to take care of it what
happens everybody pisses on the seat
because you don't have to clean the
toilet public toilets are always a mess
because no one takes care of them like I
was thinking then does it break down in
a little Society because communism
doesn't work at after 60 people or
something because there's someone in
charge work after one right and there's
always somebody in charge because like
when you remove the incentive to do
anything because everyone's getting the
same thing then it becomes about forcing
people to do something and then
people are appointed to force other
people to do stuff and then before long
it just like well just think about it if
you like what get what incentivizes you
to do things right and it there has to
be something otherwise why leave your
house why you have to leave your house
and make money because otherwise the
electricity is going to be turned off
you you know you're not going to be able
to afford things you're not going to be
able to afford food so you go out you
you do your job and you come home with
your money and you pay for things if
everything was guaranteed to you light
electricity everything you know you just
you had it what's going to incentivize
you to leave
and go be productive and go make things
and go be part of this Society you know
it's kind of like what happened in covid
and and I think to this day a lot of
people have been talking about like
there's some
something shifted in our in our culture
a little bit where people just maybe
don't necessarily want to do a job you
know
um because you were incentivized to stay
home and and it kind of it's awesome I
mean great you get to stay home and live
your life and somebody else is going to
provide for you and it just doesn't work
things don't just magically appear that
food at the supermarket doesn't
magically just go up it's not like
somebody in the back of of your
Supermarket of your local supermarket is
just like you know these things
magically come out of some you have to
grow that food you have to produce that
food who's going to do that do you
really think people want to go work the
field because they love it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time